B-1 BULLETS HIT AN ICE
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT IN
SAN ANTONIO EARLIER THIS MORNING
AND IT NOW FEDERAL OFFICIALS SAY
IT WAS A TARGETED ATTACK ON THE
BUILDING.
FOX CHIEF BREAKING NEWS
CORRESPONDENT TRACE GALLAGHER
HAS MORE ON THAT.
TERESA?
>> THE SHOOTING HAPPENED
OVERNIGHT AND A NICE FACILITY IN
SAN ANTONIO.
THERE WERE EMPLOYEES WORKING AT
THE TIME AND THEY WERE NARROWLY
MISSED AND SEVERAL WINDOWS WERE
BROKEN.
THE FBI SAYS THE LOCATION OF THE
GUNSHOTS IS NO ACCIDENT, WATCH.
>> ALL THE SHOTS THAT WE HAVE
FOUND ARE ON THE FLOORS WHERE
I.C.E. HAD OFFICERS SO IT'S NO
QUESTION IN A VERY TARGETED
ATTACK.
IT'S NOT A SECRET FACILITY, YOU
CAN GO ONLINE, IT'S OUT THERE.
THEY DID SOME RESEARCH AND THEY
KNEW WHAT FLOORS I.C.E. WAS ON
AND WHAT BUILDINGS THEY WERE IN
SO THEY HAD THOSE.
>> ONE PERSON WAS DETAINED FOR
QUESTIONING AND RELEASED.
HIS ONGOING CONCERN OVER THE
POTENTIAL FOR FUTURE ATTACKS
WITH I.C.E. SAYING "POLITICAL
RHETORIC AND MISINFORMATION THAT
VARIOUS POLITICIANS, MEDIA
OUTLETS AND ACTIVIST GROUPS
RECKLESSLY DISSEMINATE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE REGARDING THE
I.C.E. MISSION ONLY FURTHER
SERVE TO ENHANCE THESE VIOLENT
ACTS.
THIS COMES AFTER A MAN WITH A
RIFLE ATTACKED A DETENTION
CENTER OPERATED BY I.C.E. IN
TACOMA, WASHINGTON, TOSSING
INCENDIARY DEVICES THAT CARS AND
TRYING TO BLOW UP A PROPANE TANK
WHICH COULD HAVE RESULTED IN
MASS MURDER OF STAFF AND
DETAINEES.
THE MAN WAS SHOT AND KILLED BY
RESPONDING OFFICERS AND LEFT